Speaker 1: So I want to start today with something
we actually talked about on the bonus show
last week, we talked on the bonus show last
week thanks to Pat choosing the story.
Quite frankly, I hadn't even read it, which
is part of the problem.
Joe Biden
Speaker 2: has quietly, almost
Speaker 1: completely ended the drone war
that has become essentially the status quo
of American foreign policy to slightly different
degrees since George W. Bush threw Barack
Obama and including Donald Trump.
And the corporate media has barely mentioned
it.
As we were talking about it last week, I realized
we really should be talking about this more
broadly.
There's been this bizarre reversal on foreign
policy perspectives for the Republican Party,
really since Donald Trump started running
for president back in 2015, when suddenly
Republicans were pretending they don't like
war,
Speaker 2: that they
Speaker 1: don't like military incursions,
that they don't like interventionist foreign
policy when really those have been the hallmark
of neoconservative republicanism for several
decades at this point in time.
And if you think back, it sort of started
with Donald Trump saying that Iraq War, that
was a disaster.
Trump started with that,
Speaker 2: and it was
Speaker 1: always B.S.. Trump's initial political
constituency was heavily made up of people
who supported the Iraq War under George W.
Bush and admittedly, people who were sort
of right wing reactionary
Speaker 2: but were not
Speaker 1: really following politics under
George W. Bush, either because of their age
or because they just weren't paying attention.
And so they bought it.
They bought it hook, line and sinker.
Trump and Republicans, now they're against
war.
Then it went to well.
The leftists who didn't like Hillary started
building on it with the Hillary stuff, and
the Hillary's going to start for war stuff,
and Donald Trump isn't going to do that.
That became the story.
And it mostly transitioned right into Joe
Biden's presidency with this idea that if
you reelect Donald Trump, he'll keep us out
of war.
But if you elect Joe Biden, it means that
more wars are coming.
Biden was going to go to war.
I mean, I don't even remember now Biden was
going to go to war with North Korea
Speaker 2: and
Speaker 1: China and Iran and Russia and all
this different stuff now.
I said at the time, I don't see any appetite
from Joe Biden for doing those things.
Maybe I'll be proven wrong.
But there's another story here that's actually
what we're talking about today.
One of Barack Obama's biggest foreign policy
sort of conflicts with my ideology, and I
talked about this all all through the Obama
administration was the drone war.
Trump continued the drone war massively.
He didn't talk about it that much because
remember, it was killer who was going to do
the war and the bombings, not Trump.
But Trump continued Barack Obama's drone war,
which was an escalation of George W. Bush's
drone war.
Now, maybe Bush would have done more if the
technology had been more mature at the time.
Barack Obama had the benefit of that.
But now we have the reality, and the reality
is that Joe Biden has almost completely ended
the American drone war.
Joe Biden's not really saying that much about
it.
The White House isn't really saying that much
about it.
Neither is corporate media.
But it's a huge, massive story.
There was that one strike during the the Afghanistan
withdrawal, which went horribly wrong, killed
civilians.
Speaker 2: Just absolute
Speaker 1: disaster.
But Joe Biden has almost completely halted
drone strikes and airstrikes in general.
We have to call this what it is, which is
a foreign policy victory in my mind.
And it's also a communications and PR failure
by being almost completely silent about it.
Under Bush, we started droning.
Barack Obama did even more.
Donald Trump continued huge debate controversy.
But then look at what Joe Biden has now done
enters office.
First of all, sets up a system that requires
White House approval for any strike outside
of a war zone.
And listen to these numbers in Donald Trump's
first 11 months in office.
He did 6500 air and artillery strikes, per
Airwars, which tracks drone strikes in Iraq
and Syria alone.
Air Wars reports for under Joe Biden's first
11 months not 400, not 40 or 40.
As Joe Biden says, just for four of them,
air strikes in Somalia, down 75 percent from
last year to fewer than 10.
No civilian casualties in Yemen instead of
18 strikes last year, down to four.
This is a massive change, but the real question
is why the Biden White House has been so quiet
about it.
Is it because the Afghanistan air strike,
the drone strike went so wrong that they just
don't even want to talk about the fact that
there is still some droning going on?
Is it because it will lead to Joe Biden being
called weak by Republicans, which of course,
remember under Trump?
Republicans claimed they are the ones who
don't want to do interventionist foreign policy
strikes, war, etc.
But at the same time, the Republican Party
has a long history of pointing to Democrats
and saying, Oh, you don't want to go to war,
you don't want to go to Iraq, you don't want
to take this person out that well, then you're
actually the weak one.
Is it a fear of that that's keeping the Biden
administration from
Speaker 2: talking about this major
Speaker 1: accomplishment more?
Is it because Joe Biden doesn't like to brag?
I mean, a couple of people emailed means that
they said it's not Joe Biden.
Constitutionally, Joe Biden doesn't like bragging,
and that's why he's not doing it.
He's sort of he's bragged about vaccines.
He's bragged about.
I don't I don't think that that's it.
So a few different things here, number one.
Of course, there's the reality that sometimes
you're droning instead of sending in boots
on the ground.
And this was a big debate early in the big
campaigns under Barack Obama, which was, well,
we may be using drone warfare here instead
of boots on the ground.
And if either way we're going to do damage,
do we prefer it be done without boots on the
ground?
That's not the debate now.
Speaker 2: Joe Biden's not talking about.
Speaker 1: He certainly doesn't seem to be
thinking about boots on the ground.
He's just dramatically
Speaker 2: reduced drone
Speaker 1: airstrikes.
And we should be glad about that.
Let me know your thoughts.
Number one about why you don't think it's
being talked about by the Biden administration
and maybe just as importantly, number two,
why isn't the corporate media covering it?
But they may be both related things